[Music]
hello my name is michael
i am the director of microbiology
microbiology at impello biosciences
and today i'm going to be discussing
microbe ubiquity how microbes are
everywhere and the mist of sterile
cultivation systems
and the overview of content for this
presentation is i will highlight my
background briefly
i'll define some relevant terminology in
the context of this presentation we'll
talk about sterile near sterile and
non-sterile systems
both in plant cultivation and laboratory
systems
we will highlight the plant phytobiome
and look at the cannabis plant
phytobiome
we'll go over some recent papers talking
about importance the importance of plant
microbe interactions
um
and how to be conscious of your plant
microbiome during management
uh then we'll just do some concluding
remarks and that'll be it so
my name is michael velagi i was educated
at colorado state university i got a
horticulture degree in 2018 focusing on
food crop production and then i
got my master's from csu in rhizosphere
biology i've been employed as the
director of microbiology at impeller
biosciences for about two years now and
here i get to spearhead all the rnd that
appella gets to conduct
and my main research interests are plant
microbiome interactions host associated
microbiome systems and sustainability in
aggregate systems
so some terms that i just want to define
before we get into the
presentation are the word ubiquitous so
again
that's just um
present appearing or found everywhere
microbe ubiquity in this presentation is
about how most if not all micro species
are globally ubiquitous
sterile in this context is free from
bacteria or other living microorganisms
so totally clean and microbiota is just
a fancy term for all the microbes within
a habitat or on a host
and we can see on the right side of the
slide
that both our bodies here showing at
hand and plants
are
vessels to transportation vehicles for
microorganisms
so it's really hard to keep things
sterile when they're living on and
within us
so some examples of truly sterile
systems
are would be clinical laboratories this
is really
as sterile as we can get
for here we have both positive and
negative pressure rooms
in a positive pressure room air can
leave the room without circling back in
uh
the positive pressure keeps contaminants
from entering the room as air is always
emitting from the room and this also
allows staff to keep their subjects that
they're working on free from
contamination
on the contrary a negative pressure room
those keep surrounding environments
sterile or free from contaminants
and negative pressure rooms maintain a
really low air pressure to allow outside
air to enter the room
this traps contaminants into the
negative pressure room and prevents that
internal air from leaving the space
inside the negative pressure room
we don't typically see these in
cultivation systems but just to kind of
emphasize how difficult the sterility
can be to achieve
we'll just highlight two
examples of positive and negative
pressure rooms so on the left here we
have a snapshot of
an in vitro fertilization lab that's a
very sensitive cell culture technique
that is
needs to be kept clean um whereas on the
right side of the room we have a
hospital waiting room so in a in a
waiting room we have all kinds of people
with all kinds of elements we want to
keep those contingents or potential
contingents uh kept in the waiting room
and not into something like the icu
where people may be really uh sensitive
to exposure constituents so these
systems are typically the sterile this
type of sterile system is typically only
feasible in a research or clinical
setting uh now we're going to dive into
plant systems we'll start with uh truly
sterile and get down to high microbial
biome
so first and foremost one example of a
truly sterile system in plant research
would be this i want to highlight this
tool called the eco fab which stands for
ecosystem fabrication
this system is truly sterile but it
allows the controlled addition of
microorganisms in interest of studying
how microbes interact with the plant
so this this device is designed to
control the introduction and sampling of
microbes in the plant roots or on the
plants as well as plant or micro
produced metabolites in the system
this is a great way to study plants in a
laboratory with strong efforts to
control
the plant's natural growing environment
so this is almost as close as you can
get to a sterile system in plant growth
while still having outside inputs from
the environment but the user gets to
control them
and here's just a flowchart of power on
one how one might set up one of these
systems starting plants in sterile
tissue culture
transferring them to the eco febs device
the optional addition of microbes
and then you would just kind of change
the liquid medium as you fit
and monitor root growth and plant growth
throughout the system
you can non-destructively sample this
system and then when you it is time to
fully harvest and see how you're planted
you would destructively sample it check
out the microbes check out the roots and
check out the shoots
so these are typically employed in
metabolomic or molecular biology related
studies for plant metabolism and this is
about as sterile as we can get in plant
research
another example
this is a little bit less sterile but it
would be tissue culture
as
we are aware
this technique is often used for clean
stock production or for researchers to
study plants or plant behavior in the
absence of microorganisms
these assays are performed
inside petri dishes or test tubes
things that can be sterile on the inside
and don't really need to be opened until
it's time to sample
so you need to sterilize your plants
with light surfactant like bleach or
rubbing alcohol prior to introducing
these systems
and
if you don't sterilize your plants
properly anything that could be living
on the plants as we saw in the earlier
slide with all the microbes on both the
hand and the plant
um can actually out compete
the plants for nutrients contained in
this agar medium
so that's why it's really important to
keep things sterile in here and this is
a way to study the plant in isolation of
microbes
moving forward
the next tier
into near sterility would be a growth
chamber environment
these often contain either tissue
culture vessels or potted plant
experiments
these devices can provide year-round
climate control and also if mechanical
issues arise on this
more often than not they can be fixed
from outside of the chamber without
opening up and jeopardizing the
sterility of the inside
the oxygen or the air intake and exhaust
for these systems can be hepa filtered
just adding another barrier of sterility
and containment
and because this is a small room that
usually the user's arms are only in or
so
it reduces the foot traffic compared to
a greenhouse research bay um so again
limiting the amount of microbial
vessels like humans or plants to
disseminate microbes in the sterile
system
and then these are
often used for clean stock production
like tissue culture
or
to just really control your environment
a little bit more fine-tune a greenhouse
uh the next tier away from this away
from truly sterile systems would be
lots of hydroponic or deep water culture
systems i like to call these low
microbial biomass systems
you won't see this in aquaponics because
the fish waste is actually converted
into a plant available form of nitrogen
with a microbial transformation it's a
bacteria
so aquaponics don't fall into low
microbial biomass systems but aeroponics
and hydroponics and systems like that do
typically the only microbes in this
system outside of what's coming on the
grower are applied biological inputs
such as mycorrhizae or plant growth
promoting bacteria
and one thing that growers usually do in
these systems is employ sanitizers uh i
have a picture a small icon of an ozone
generator on the left and the formula
for hydrogen peroxide on the right two
very common surfactants or sanitizers
used in the steep water culture system
or a a hydroponic system
because that will limit microbial
biomass
preventing biofilms and algae builds up
buildups and things like that
and often in these systems
because the microbial conversion of
unavailable nutrients is not needed uh
these systems also often employ salt
based plant available nutrients um
so plants can uptake them readily uh and
so can free living microbes that we'll
talk about in just a little bit
so
the opposite of everything we just
covered would be a high microbial
biomass system or uh also called a
living soil cultivation system
this is typically when growers are
cultivating both the plants and the
soils that they're growing at
some benefits to these systems include
high microbial diversity and we will
talk about some benefits that that can
bring to your plants in a couple slides
uh this having living soil systems also
can
make sure you have a balance in your
soil food web and the soil food web is a
microbial food chain that helps organic
matter and other decaying materials get
recycled and converted into plant
beneficial compounds like humic acids
and fulvic acids and organic matter
so these microbial ecosystem services
are much more often
in higher
higher abundances when you're in living
soil systems as opposed to a soilless or
substrate
less cultivation systems
and also with lots of microorganisms
things like fungi can make a lot more
pore space in the root zone which allows
more oxygen both to the roots and
microbial communities because typically
our pathogens are anaerobic and our
beneficials are aerobic microorganisms
so more oxygen means less favorable
conditions for plant pathogens to
survive
to some degree
so why would somebody employ this type
of system
um
when they are considering the plant's
microbiome or the phytobiome in their
in their cultivation techniques
so now i want to talk about the plant
phytobiome for a while
breaking down the definition of this is
phytoplant biome is ecological area
and the phytobiome includes the plant
host the surrounding growing environment
as well as all organisms living within
or on the plant host
and even the cannabis plant has a has a
photobiome
this review
by the authors in the bottom right
corner of this figure
they conducted a review of 122 papers
and determined the most common genus
level bacteria and fungi
occurring in different tissues of the
cannabis plant so from the buds seeds
leaves petioles stems and the roots
these are the most occurring genera that
have been published about
um
on the cannabis plant so we can see the
blue our bacteria and the red names are
fungal genera
so the cannabis plant even has its own
phytobiomes and there's probably things
that these authors have left out in just
looking at 122 papers from different
geographical areas but
what i want to emphasize here is that
although lots of growers consider
sterile systems
the cannabis plant does want to have
symbiotic microorganisms on top and
inside of it
now we're just going to do a quick
overview of major plant endophytes
and primarily these are going to be
bacteria and fungi
first the first group i want to cover
are mycorrhizal fungi so these can be
either ectomycorrhizae or arbuscular
mycorrhizae
actin mycorrhizae typically form
relationships with woody plants whereas
the arbuscular mycorrhizae fungi are
non-woody plants so flowering plants and
ferns things like that
the biggest difference in the context of
this presentation is that the
ectomycorrhizae
live outside of the roots in kind of
formed like a shield whereas the
arbuscular mycorrhizae can enter root
cells
also sometimes called endomycorrhizae
and
pretty much all
plant symbiotic fungi can help with
phosphorus uptake especially the
mycorrhizae
second to that would be non-mycorrhizal
fungal ionophytes so these things are
typically found to live in or on your
plants
and either the function is undetermined
but mostly these things are
non-pathogenic
and likely not beneficial either just
kind of commensal things that live on
your plant
so all this red text our fungal genera
from the cannabis plant slide that have
been found to live on different organs
or tissues of the plant
whether or not these things are
commensal or beneficial is still
undetermined as as the literature
evolves
moving forward to bacteria everybody's
likely heard of rhizobium
bacteria so these are
bacteria that
can fix nitrogen from the atmosphere
allowing it to become a plant available
form of nitrogen these bacteria make
homes in the roots of plants and the
genus or the family of plants
that these bacteria can form
relationships with is fca or the legume
plant family
so they make little houses in the form
of root nodules in the roots and they
convert atmospheric nitrogen from the
atmosphere into the plant available form
allowing the plant to take nitrogen up
from the atmosphere surrounding it
and then non-modulating bacteria are
typically referred to as plant growth
promoting bacteria or plant growth
promoting rhizobacteria depending on if
they're present on the plants or in the
roots or the rhizosphere system
and non-modulating bacteria can help
with mineral nutrient uptake things like
iron conversion and phosphorus
conversion they can produce plant
hormones like auxin
which
increases the root surface area of the
plants allowing the plants to have
stronger ties to the earth and
structural support and then giving more
surface area to these beneficial
microbes we keep talking about
they can also induce plant post
resistance genes and compete directly
with phytopathogens and we'll go into
some examples of that in a few slides
um
but there you know while there are a
bunch of beneficial bacteria and fungi
associated with plants we can't we can't
discount the pathogenic organisms so
we'll broadly cover some pathogenic
microbes um pathogenic microbes can best
be defined as those that cause plant
disease another word for these would be
phytopathogens phyto plant pathogens
disease causing
some examples of common genus or genera
of plants disease causing microbes would
be fusarium alternaria
xanthomonas botrytis a lot of those
nasty microbes you hear about um on the
left side of this
slide we see a plant uh infected with
fusarium
um
fusarium oxy-sporum wilt it's clogging
the vascular system of this temp plant
in an ipm study
um phytopathogens can also become
advantageous when the host plant is weak
or whether it's living in an imbalanced
microbial community system
these are called opportunistic pathogens
so when a plant is suffering from
drought stress it can be easier for
certain fungi or bacteria to infect the
plant when it's
trying to recover
uh from an alternative stress so they're
opportunistic pathogens because they use
the weakened plant as an opportunity to
infect it more
better than it would if the plant was in
a healthy system
um
we can't talk about pathogens without
talking about these alleviation methods
and some three common ones would be
chemical treatments so chemical
fungicides are
antibiotics however these can also hurt
your beneficial microbial community so
use those with caution
um
another cool way is that neighboring uh
plant growth promoting bacteria
in the in the system can help inhibit
the growth of plato pathogens
we see here a petri dish from the
impella lab with three colonies of
bacillus in the top the left and the
bottom right
inhibiting the growth of the fungus
fusarium oxysporum which is protruding
from the center of this petri dish so
where you see the
smears kind of where the t symbols are
we can see the inhibition of fungal
mycelium growth
by the production of antifungal peptides
of bacillus genus bacteria
um so just wanted to have a visual aid
for how these these microbes can talk to
one another and how some beneficial
bacteria can keep
uh pathogenic fungi at bay um
and yeah another way to to get pathogens
out of your systems is to restore
balance in soil microbial communities
and we can talk about some ways to do
that in a later in the presentation
um now i want to emphasize
balancing the phytobiome and why it's so
important for plant health growth and
development
so this paper by posh and he that came
out in 2021 emphasized some key points
one being that any changes in a plant's
natural microbiota
it's microbial communities associated
with it and the roots on the body
can either cause positive or negative
effects in the plant health
um homeostasis is one of the ideal
situations for your plant health this
can also be called ubiosis and this
prevents community imbalances
and the presence of beneficial microbes
can assist the plant and growth of
development through some of the
functions we've talked about a couple of
slides ago
as well as how these microbes can
directly compete with pathogens
that can cause disease
just for resources whether or not
they're preventing pathogens from
affecting the plant they're just out
competing the pathogens for things like
carbon in the rhizosphere
allowing the phytopathogens to become
unsuccessful in causing disease
because they're just not getting enough
food to grow in high enough cell numbers
to infect your plant
zooming in on this figure a little bit
i just want to break these three terms
down and define them a little bit more
in the context of this presentation this
is also from the pasha e paper
so microbial dysbiosis is usually
resulting from a disruption in the
microbiome
caused by stress or external factors and
this can be associated with host disease
or making a plant more vulnerable
so an example of this in a in a field
system could look like hail happening
causing a wound on the plant and then an
opportunistic pathogen infecting that
wound for a plant
microbial ubiosis also called also
called homeostasis is a balance or
equilibrium between different elements
in the system so the plant host
and then positive or negative
plant-benefiting microbes are also kind
of in balance with one another
and then this paper also defined a new
term called
malayarbiosis which is after
a disruption is caused in the
homeostasis of the microbiome
things shift in such a way to cause
positive effects on the plant hosts
under stress or disease
so one example of this could look like
um
halophyte or salt tolerating
microorganisms colonizing the root zone
to allow the plants to
uh survive better in high saline soils
and usually soils can become higher in
salts when using salt-based fertilizers
and the water evaporates leaving salts
behind
um
so here we are just going to highlight
uh four instances four different studies
about plants
wanting microbiota
um just some evidence to suggest that
plants are actively trying to recruit
their microbial communities
and how
when they're not able to do that their
growth can be a little bit stunted in
systems that don't have a good selection
full of microbes
so this study here came out in 2013 and
it wanted to see if using a different
nutrient solution as opposed to your
typical salt-based nutrients in a
hydroponic system
um was helpful at preventing disease uh
after inoculating piecerium oxysporum so
their nutrient solution just consisted
of more organic matter and they refer to
it as a multiple parallel mineralization
system
their testing crops in this study were
lettuce and tomato
and they were able to show
that the disease-causing organism
pieterium oxysporum could be present in
the system but was unable to cause any
diseases on the plants
and when other microbes were present the
total
number of living cells of the fusarium
was much reduced you can see in the
upper right corner of the slide that in
the inorganic typical hydroponic
nutrient system there was a
significantly higher amount of fusarium
colony forming units per milliliter of
nutrient solution as suppose as opposed
to the mpm or multiple parallel
mineralization system so the main
takeaway from this study is that it's
possible for plants and pathogens to
coexist in a system when other
microbiota are able to be present and
suppress populations of disease causing
organisms
moving forward another example of how
plants want microbiota um the second
study i want to highlight was by
chaparro at all
and they they basically wanted to see if
plant deposited sugars also called fruit
exits
change over development with the plants
so through vegetative and seedling
flowering growth
and then they also wanted to see how
these changes in compounds
could affect the microbiota or the
microbes in the soil
so they used arabidops saliana which was
just like a wild mustard that also like
the lab rat of plant research
and they showed that root exit has
changed over time with sugars containing
microbial accessible carbon deposited
high and in higher numbers during early
growth and then phenolics and amino acid
compounds were deposited higher in later
growth stages
they also showed that microbes responded
to these changes in root exit
by increasing the presence of
functional genes that could use these
compounds as microbe food so basically
when there was more sugar there was more
microbes in the soil that could eat the
sugar and grow when there were more
phenolics and amino acids the same thing
happened more microbes that could
metabolize those compounds for energy
we're growing
so the main takeaways from this study
are that plant you know plant deposited
compounds can change over growth and
development and these are likely to
accommodate the developmental needs of
the plant
microbes and surrounding soils
absolutely are responding to these
changes in compounds and likely
colonizing the root zones um and and
speculatively
uh plants are depositing these exits in
efforts to recruit their microbial
communities
another study also using arabidopsis and
another wild mustard called medical
trunculata
were used
to examine the relationship between
those two plants and their fungal
microbiome in an agro ecosystem where
these crops are grown every year
the authors of this study showed that
when
these plants were taken out of their
native agri-ecosystem soils they could
maintain the soil fungal populations
the same type of fungi in their native
soils as to when they were potted up in
the greenhouse
they speculated that that was from the
root exodus of these plants so they also
generated root exudates in sterile
systems like the tissue culture we saw
earlier collected those exodus and then
applied those exodus to the soils and
the absence of the plant
and they were able to demonstrate that
these same fungi were able to grow and
proliferate in cell numbers
when these root adidas were applied in
the absence of the plant so the main
takeaways here are that plant micro
symbioses are likely initiated by root
exits of the host plant
and a very cool takeaway here
is that
the fungi were able to grow when fed
root exodus and absence of the plants
because there are forms of microbially
acceptable carbon contained in rooting
lastly
we talked hi or i talked earlier about
how certain microbes can help plants
survive and grow better under times of
abiotic stress and so i want to
highlight an ongoing study from
impello's research and development
in this study we wanted to see if plants
could recruit microbes in response to
stress and if these microbes were able
to assist plant and growth and
development under stress
we showed that we hear two generations
of hemp and tomato plants
under drop stress in the first
generation in living soil systems we
then collected the resulting soils in
the roots of generation one and applied
those to a second generation of the same
plant species
after the study was over we saw that
the first generation plants were able to
survive the drought stress like they do
to colonizing microbes and then we saw
in the second generation
that
when they received microbes from the
first generation plants in the second
generation had significantly increased
biomass
compared to plants under severe drought
that did not get microbes so on the
right side here we see the blue bars are
plants from hemp and tomato that did not
get microbes inoculated from generation
one
and the tan bars are ones that did get
inoculated microbes from the plants in
generation one and they were able to
perform significantly better um when
using the
generation one microbes that were
recruited under drought stress
one caveat i really want to mention with
talking you know with knocking sterile
systems as much as i am in this
presentation is that we should all still
keep cleaning especially
our indoor cultivation systems anytime
you bring something living outside it's
going to come with its own microbes and
free living microbes
that are going to cause contaminants and
problems
so while it is good to have lots of
microbial diversity
it's also good to keep things that are
really good at growing like algae in
czech so they don't out compete with
your plants
for plant available nutrients
so cleaning is good because it can
remove free living microbes the best
example of a free living microbe would
be algae when you get those green
biofilms and slimes in your nutrient
solutions that's because the algae is
eating the nitrogen that your plants
want
cleaning can also disrupt established
microbes in such a way to
to allow better micro micro competition
to restore some type of balance if
after populations are
dampened with a with a good cleaning
event
thus lowering the microbial load in the
system
that can help uh plants colonize more
beneficials through root exits as we saw
earlier
um one example
um authors showed from a study in 2019
was that moist heat sterilization was
applied to a diseased soil
which was able to reduce populations of
disease causing microorganisms
and then when plants were grown in those
soils after sterilizing them or
disrupting them the newly grown plants
were able to restore microbial balance
in the soil or ubiosis in the soil so
even though the disease-causing
organisms were present they were unable
to achieve pathogenicity on the plants
and that was in a living soil system
as opposed to like a hydroponic system
so cleaning is both good
when you can do it
because it can help
lessen high microbial populations and
allow your plants to selectively feed
things to a degree to get more of a
microbial balance
so some just general tips for
incorporating your plants microbiome
into your management practice
would be to you know make sure to
implement good watering practice i just
lightly touched on this earlier but
both your plant roots and your microbes
need oxygen too
so when you can open you over underwater
plants this is limiting the amount of
oxygen or adding too much oxygen where
things are drying out
the second do would be to try to
incorporate non-salt-based fertilizers
for nitrogen phosphorus and potassium
when possible
obviously it'll be
easiest to alternate rather than switch
from salts to organic materials
immediately but these organic materials
can provide food sources in the form of
microbially accessible carbon
in addition to the plant root exodus
that the plants are already exuding into
your system
so if you use exclusively salt-based
fertilizer this is pretty much only
giving inoculated microbes in your
system
um food from the plant root exits only
so you want to give them a little bit
more food some people use like molasses
and home grows and things like that
make sure to separate any biological
inoculants you're using
in time from applying sanitizers so if
you apply a sanitizer to your system
it's always a healthy or a good choice
to reapply a biological input within 24
to 72 hours at minimum um
because you know these sanitizers are
non-selective they can hurt your
beneficials so don't waste your time and
don't waste your money
make sure to give some space between
applying sanitizers and biologicals so
you're not just sanitizing your
biologicals out of the system
and then the over-application of
sanitizers most people do this to try to
prevent any disease-causing organisms
can also get rid of your beneficials
that your plants are trying to recruit
with their
root exit it so be mindful of that
and of course
alternating chemical and biological ipm
practices
when possible so like for pest control
or microbial pathogen control
alternating chemicals and biologicals is
always a really good idea
as we just talked about certain
chemicals can also disrupt your
beneficial communities
and lastly
it's always good practice to keep your
grow areas tidy from any type of plant
debris or
you know loose soil or soilless
cultivation
debris
because certain
you know a piece of rock wool with
nitrogen in it can grow algae and other
pathogenic organisms or other organisms
that have the potential to be pathogenic
and plants that are you know dead leaves
that are in your system can also breed
things like pathogens so
never stop cleaning
but
be mindful of your plants phytobiome
when you are cleaning
so some just general takeaways are that
um sterile doesn't always necessarily
mean good for plant growth and
development as we've seen through
a bunch of examples of plant microbe
interactions covered today
um
secondly just kind of wanted to
highlight some recent developments and
understanding the interactions between
plants and their associated microbial
communities
and lastly i hope everybody takes away a
little bit more thought into
beginning to or continue to consider the
microbiome of your plants during
management
these are my peer-reviewed literature
references in order of appearance
if you guys have any further reading
interest from anything covered today
especially those four studies i kind of
sped through
and secondly image references
and with that
that was my presentation thank you so
much for your time and assistance and
my email address is on the first slide
should you have any questions you can
email me thank you
you